[Applaus]
[Musik]
heute meine lieben freunde von visual
politik möchte ich euch eine kleine
frage stellen bis die eigentlich wie man
das bruttoinlandsprodukt eines landes
berechnet und wer es berechnet ich wette
nicht so genau
[Musik]
aber trotzdem benutzt ihr diese schöne
zahl das bruttoinlandsprodukt gerne um
länder miteinander zu vergleichen oder
ja ganz schön nah ich muss ich sagen ich
meine
woher kommt die ganze datenbasis um zu
messen wie es um die wirtschaft eines
landes bestellt ist was meinen wir
wirklich damit wenn wir sagen dass
chinas bruttoinlandsprodukt um
beispielsweise sieben prozent pro jahr
wächst nun sehen wir uns die sache mal
etwas aus der nähe
[Musik]
also ganz allgemein kann man sagen das
bruttoinlandsprodukt kurz bip basiert
auf einer reihe von statistiken
untersuchungen und erhebungen richtig
aber wer gibt all diesen bericht den
auftrag natürlich die regierung jedes
landes und wäre gilt china
ja das ist die kommunistische partei
chinas die jetzt kommt ja eigentlich
frage was wenn die ihre zahlen
menschen würden bis endlich wissen wir
dass peking viel geld für propaganda
ausgibt letztlich muss das chinesische
volk glauben gemacht werden dass es im
westen aller länder liegt und dass die
regierung von jean ping irland
unübertrefflich gut regiert baum also
nicht die propagandamaschinerie auch auf
die makroökonomischen zahlen loslassen
was ist wenn wir die ganze zeit mit den
falschen zahlen gearbeitet haben zwar
kann niemand leugnen dass china in den
letzten jahrzehnten gewachsen ist dazu
muss man sich nur ein foto von jenson
von vor 20 jahren ansehen und mit dem
heutigen stadtbild vergleichen aber
nicht nur das der beste beweis dafür
dass china tatsächlich wie verrückt
wächst ist die tatsache dass viele
westliche unternehmen beginnen auf dem
chinesischen festland immer mehr waren
zu verkaufen denn eine firma wie zum
beispiel lego ist ja keine wohl fast
verein sondern eine knallharte
kalkulierende hyper kapitalistische
organisation sie würde diesen markt
nicht in betracht ziehen wenn es dort
nicht jedes jahr mehr und mehr
konsumenten gebe immer mehr und mehr
geld auszugeben bereit sind also ja
china wächst aber wie schnell willkommen
in der wunderbaren welt der nur und
glaube es wäre nicht das erste mal dass
ein staat sich seine zahlen zusammen
liegt tatsächlich passiert sowas viel
häufiger als man erwarten
[Musik]
satellitenbilder zeigen welche länder
war der wirtschaftsstatistik betrügen
wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt jugend
autoritäre regierungen viel er
letztendlich gibt es in diesen ländern
keine legale opposition keine
regierungskritischen medien und keine
unabhängige institutionen die ihre
eigene untersuchung durchführen und
veröffentlichen können
dies war die ursprüngliche hypothese und
der wir hier bei visual politik
ausgegangen sind denn im grunde wäre es
doch geradezu unlogisch für china seine
zahlen nicht zu manipulieren also
begannen wir mit unseren recherchen und
voila
wir stießen auf folgendes
laut einer neuen studie hat china die
bip-daten für mindestens neun jahre um
zwei punkte übertrieben na bitte ins
schwarze getroffen
aber gut es handelt sich nur um eine
einzelne studie wie ihr wisst reicht uns
bei visual politik keine einzelquelle
noch nicht zum beweis
also haben wir diese studie sorgfältig
gelesen sie mit anderen ähnlichen studie
verglichen und dieses video gedreht
damit ihr euch auch in unseren
erkenntnissen lassen könnte die heutigen
fragen lauten also in china in bezug auf
seinen bip als dies der fall sein sollte
wieso warum sollten es überhaupt gegen
wollen und natürlich die wichtigste
frage von allen die lautet eigentlich
die wirkliche korrekte definition des
bip heute werden wir alle diese fragen
beantworten doch zuvor wollen wir einen
blick zurück in die geschichte des bip
wer misst das bruttoinlandsprodukt das
bruttoinlandsprodukt ist ein konzept das
1932 von einem russisch amerikanischen
wirtschaftswissenschaftler namens simone
q cells entwickelt wurde nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg wurde es als grundlage
für die berechnung von geldtransfers im
rahmen des marshallplans verwendet damit
etabliert es sich als standard was aber
moment mal was eigentlich misst das bip
tatsächlich komm schon
ich bin sicher du weißt es vielleicht
doch nicht keine sorge du bist nicht
alleine
wir reden über das bip häufig ohne
wirklich zu wissen wovon wir da
überhaupt drehen aber keine angst wir
werden euch ist alles darüber parat
das bip ist die summe aller in einem
land oder einer region während eines
zeitraums in der regel einem jahr
produzierten endprodukte das bedeutet
das ist über den reichtum hinaus
wirtschaftliche leistung
wenn man zum beispiel ölfelder besitzt
daraus aber kein erdöl punkt hat dies
natürlich keinen einfluss auf das bip
oder wenn man eine fabrik sein eigen
nennt diese aber auch die produktion für
einige einstellt kann dadurch auch
nichts zum bip hinzuaddiert werden
aber sobald diese fabrik ein auto
produziert dann erhöht sich das bip um
den betrag des marktpreises dieses autos
mit anderen worten mehr als das
statisches vermögen zeigt das bip also
die gesundheit einer wirtschaften es ist
nicht wichtig was man besitzt sondern
was man produziert und ja wir sprechen
immer über endprodukte sagen wir zum
beispiel wir betreiben ein restaurant
und bereiten für unsere gäste einen
salat zu wir verwenden dazu als zutaten
einen salatkopf eine tomate und eine
zwiebel nehmen wir der einfachheit
halber mal an
jede dieser zutaten würde genau einen
euro kosten und mehr verkaufen den
ganzen stars für fünf euro dann erhöhen
wir das bip um dieses euro weil der
salat das endprodukt ist dass die
verbraucher kaufen werden eine weitere
sehr wichtige sache die wir über das bip
wissen müssen ist dass es nur neu
hergestellte produkte berücksichtigt aus
diesem grund zählt die transaktion beim
kauf eines gebrauchtwagens oder eines
altbaus nicht zum bip aber wenn man ein
nagelneues haus errichtet und verkauft
dann wird sein marktwert im bip
berücksichtigt klingt für den anfang
doch eigentlich recht gut als maß für
die leistungsfähigkeit einer
volkswirtschaft oder
[Musik]
den aufmerksamen unter euch wird aber
sicher aufgefallen sein dass dies noch
nicht die ganze wahrheit sein kann dann
eine volkswirtschaft basiert doch auch
viel fehlen mehr als materiellen fertig
gütern die zu einem marktpreis verkauft
werden was passiert denn mit all den
dienstleistungen die materiell erbracht
werden wird er dafür erbrachte aufwand
und ihre bedeutung für die
volkswirtschaft einfach ignoriert und
was es mit jenem sachen und diensten die
überhaupt nicht zum marktpreisen
verkauft werden nämlich praktisch allem
was der staat macht in der öffentlichen
verwaltung arbeiten doch millionen von
menschen fall alle leistungen die sie
für den bürger erbringen einfach unter
den tisch ganz und gar nicht im bip wird
auch dies alles berücksichtigt
allerdings geht es hier nicht mehr so
logisch und stringenz wie bei den
verkauften endprodukt tatsächlich machen
die hersteller materielle endprodukte
nämlich das produzierende gewerbe und
die bauwirtschaft zusammen weniger als
ein drittel der im bip gemessene
wirtschaftsleistung aus zumindest in
deutschland das doch sogar als land mit
um industrieanteil gilt die restlichen
zwei drittel des bip werden aus allen
arten von dies leistungen berechnet da
wären zum beispiel banken versicherungen
vermietung verkehrsbetriebe und so
weiter gut alle diese dienste werden in
der regel vom markt preisen erbracht
wenn du dir also von seinem friseur für
zwölf euro die haare schneiden lässt
hört sich das bip dadurch um diese zwölf
euro und auch wenn du für deine kfz
haftpflichtversicherung jährlich 200
euro bezahlst erhöht sich um diesen
betrag der bpk eines landes hierbei
wirst du vielleicht schon ein wenig
kritisch den kopf neigen oder denn was
beeinflusst die höhe des
versicherungsbeitrags da wir davon
ausgehen können dass es sich um einen
durch faire konkurrenz ausbalancierten
marktpreis handelt vor allem durch einen
faktor die unfallkosten aller
versicherungen also letztendlich die
höhe der schäden welche die versicherung
bezahlen muss denn diese werden ja durch
den versicherungs beitrag einfach auf
jeden einzelnen versicherten umgelegt
gut aber wird eine volkswirtschaft
wirklich umso leistungsfähiger je mehr
unfälle die leute bauen und wenn du
schon an dieser stelle etwas skeptisch
wirst was die aussagekraft des bip
angeht hörte erst mal an wie der
staatsanteil
daran berichtet wird
[Musik]
für die leistungen die der staat
erbringt gibt es eher in der regel
keinen marktpreis
denn entweder sind sie kostenlos wie zum
beispiel der schutz und die hilfe die
ihr die polizei bietet oder zum beispiel
im kriegsfall das militär das deine
freiheit an allen möglichen orten der
welt verteidigt oder der staat als
monopolist legt irgendwelche gebühren
fest die aber nur in den wenigsten
fällen die leistung widerspiegeln die
sich dahinter verbirgt also haben sich
die ökonomen einen trick einfallen
lassen um den staatsanteil an der
wirtschaftsleistung in die einfließen zu
lassen
und ich wette dass der erst mal liegt
kinnlade runterfällt wenn du hörst
wurden dieser trick besteht diese
schlaumeier haben sich nämlich gesagt
gehen wir doch der einfachheit halber
mal davon aus dass der marktpreis für
die leistungen des staates exakt ihren
kosten entspricht warum was für ein
genie streich das heißt je teurer und
ineffizienter der stadt arbeitet desto
höher fällt das bip seiner
volkswirtschaft aus somit sind von
staatsseite her der manipulation des bip
nämlich tür und tor geöffnet und das
quasi in allen ländern und wenn ihr es
dachte das war's mit den schlechten
nachrichten bezüglich der bestimmung des
bip was ich euch schon wieder
enttäuschen schauen wir uns nämlich mal
an woher die ganzen daten zu seiner
berechnung herkommen gehen die
statistiker etwa einen jedes einzelne
unternehmen und sowie der familie um sie
zu befragen was sie da so produzieren
und was sie konsumieren nein nein es
werden nur stichproben
[Musik]
in den meisten ländern gibt es gesetze
die die unternehmen dazu verpflichten
ihre zahlen den statistikämtern
offenzulegen
diese zahl werden dann im rahmen von
schätzungen hochgerechnet wodurch sich
natürlich schon wieder neue
möglichkeiten der forschung ergeben zb
durch ein geschicktes maßschneidern der
stichprobe und jetzt fragt ihr euch
sicher bei alldem schmude hier getrieben
werden kann hat das bip dann überhaupt
als maßzahl zum vergleich von
volkswirtschaften irgendeine art von
aussagekraft nun überraschenderweise ja
ist es sogar eines der besten werkzeuge
die wir dazu haben denn eigentlich
brauchen wir die ganzen bisher nur als
relative zahlen die dann miteinander
verglichen werden können sowohl zwischen
einzelnen ländern als auch von jahr zu
jahr
ok wie kommt man dann zu dieser
vergleichbarkeit dazu nehmen
verschiedene internationale
organisationen die rohdaten her und
nehmen ihre eigenen schätzungen vor die
sich zum beispiel hat ihr eigenes
facebook und auch die weltbank oder der
internationale währungsfonds führen ihre
eigenen unabhängigen statistiken denn es
gab schon viele fälle in denen
verschiedene regierungen betrogen haben
auch viele demokratische staaten wie zb
griechenland oder argentinien
es gibt aber auch noch viele andere
methoden um sicherzustellen dass die bps
in relation zueinander und ihre
entwicklung von jahr zu jahr genau
gemessen werden können wir können zum
beispiel die import und export zahlen
oder die steuereinnahmen vergleichen
hier ist es wird viel schwieriger zu
tricksen seit einigen jahren werden auch
satellitenbilder verwendet es stellt
sich heraus dass dies ein sehr genaues
system zur messung des wachstums eines
landes ein
und eines ist sicher bilder wie dieses
sind äußerst aufschlussreich
ok jetzt ist ihr alles wichtige darüber
wie das bip bestimmt und kontrolliert
wird kommen wir nun also zu unserem
kommunistischen freunden in china lösung
sind ihre zahlen korrekt sehen wir uns
das mal etwas genauer an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ideale politisches system stellt ihr
ein land vor
in die nur die besten ausgebildeten und
bürger in die politik kommen kann ja ein
politisches system in dem es keine wahl
und keine demokratie gibt in dem aber
statt lehrer politiker versprechen echte
talente und reale ergebnisse belohnt
werden ich bin mir sicher viele von euch
hätten überhaupt nichts dagegen an einem
ort mit einem solchen politischen system
zu leben oder nun diese ortet einen
namen die volksrepublik china
wir stellen vor das kann das system in
china ist politiker im gespräch bin
einfach nur ein weiterer beruf unter
vielen anderen und da es keine wahlen
gibt kann man nur ganz unten anfangen
und sich dann auf der karriereleiter
hoch arbeit in dieser hinsicht gehe
dieses system einer typischen karriere
bei den big four dem globalen oligopol
der vier größten
wirtschaftsprüfungsgesellschaften man
beginnt als kleiner journalist und
steigt nach und nach auf bis man partner
wird tatsächlich wurde dieses politische
system von deng xiaoping dem architekten
des heutigen china geschaffen die im
westen kennen wir den shopping als den
mann der chinas wirtschaft geöffnet hat
dort gilt er aber auch als der mann der
die meritokratie nach china gebracht hat
vor ihm zwei auszeiten wurden
chinesische politiker danach befördert
wie hingebungsvoll sie den gottgleichen
führer an hamilton und die fanatisch sie
den kommunismus und seine unfehlbaren
dogmen an diesen
doch in den 1980 er jahren änderte sich
in china so einiges man begann die
politiker danach zu beurteilen ob sie
die ihnen gesteckten ziele auch
erreichen außerdem hatte 1978 nur 26
prozent der chinesischen führungskräfte
an der universität studiert bis zum jahr
1990 stieg diese zahl auf über 90
prozent steil an aber der wendepunkt in
dieser geschichte ist zweifellos das
jahr 1998 damals änderte die
kommunistische partei chinas ist das
gesetz welches das bewertungssystem
regelte danach würde ich ihn nie mehr
das land sein das es vorher war
seitdem werden die führungskräfte anhand
vergleichender leistungsindikatoren
beurteilt wenn zb der gouverneur der
provinz viel schlechtere ergebnisse als
seine nachbarn an zentrale committee
meldet wird er probleme bekommen
[Musik]
die ziele sind realistisch bemessen
genauso wie die strafe wenn man sie
nicht erreicht im jahre 2005 wurde der
bürgermeister der stadt in dem die
chemie.de liegt degradiert warum er hat
nicht alles getan was er konnte um einen
unfall zu vermeiden
darüber hinaus wird viel augenmerk auf
die korruptionsbekämpfung gelegt wenn
ein funktionär erwischt wird kann ihn
die sein leben kosten
tja so gesehen hört sich das politische
system im kommunistischen china
doch gar nicht mehr so schlecht oder nun
wartet mit ihrem urteil noch einen
moment denn die wir hier bei visual
politik immer sagen der teufel steckt im
detail
beim solitär schummeln was war die woher
kommen die ganzen zahlen um das bip
chinas zu berechnen manche aus peking
nein wir einen so riesigen land zwischen
statistiken durch die einzelnen
provinzregierung erstellt werden und
natürlich können die provinzgouverneure
dort keine schlechteren zahlen vorlegen
als ist das zentralkomitee von ihnen
erwartet was also machen sie bin mir
sicher ihr habt es bereits verraten
sie erzählen blicken einfach das was ist
von ihnen hören möchte
diese tatsache ist so bekannt dass man
sich sogar in peking vollkommen klar
darüber ist und ihr fragt euch
vielleicht aber marco schlaumeier woher
willst du bitte schön wissen dass tekken
weiß und was es nicht weiß ganz einfach
wenn wir die aus den einzelnen provinzen
gemeldet
die ips zusammenzählen erhalten wir als
eine ganz andere zahl als die offizielle
die von chinas zentralregierung für ganz
china angegeben wird ja ihr habt
vollkommen richtig gehört ja korrigiert
gegen die steuerschätzung in der
regionalen statistikbehörden mit anderen
worten in china gegen die
provinzgouverneure vor die wahrheit zu
sagen und die zentralregierung tut so
als ob sie daran glauben würde jeder
lügt und jeder tut so als wäre er
glücklich schaut euch einfach mal dieses
diagramm
[Musik]
[Applaus]
natürlich wenn die zahlen genau wären
würden sich beide linien überlappen aber
wie ihr sehen könnt tun sie das nicht
tatsächlich können wir hier ein muster
erkennt bis 2006 waren die lokalen dps
niedriger als das offizielle für ganz
hier aber danach lief es genau umgekehrt
dies könnte eine unbeabsichtigte folge
der zu diesem zeitpunkt ihre volle
wirkung entfalten politik der
meritokratie gewesen zu sein denn nun
wurde von den provinzgouverneuren
erwartet dass sie sich so viel wie
möglich ins zeug legen was bewirkt dass
diese ihre zahlen künstlich aufgebläht
haben aber eine frage bleibt da noch
woher weiß peking wie es die zahlen denn
anpassen müssen die wahrheit ist wir
haben keine ahnung was wir aber wissen
ist wie die wissenschaftler von der
brookings institution einer
amerikanischen denkfabrik dieses
kunststück vollbracht haben so haben sie
zum beispiel die offiziellen
wirtschaftsstatistiken mit dem
steuerstatistik geplant
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist ein wenig schwieriger bei den
steuereinnahmen zu betrügen da es sich
dabei ja nicht nur um eine schätzung
handelt sondern um reales geld das auf
das konto der regierung fließt und wir
können dabei immer gut zurückverfolgen
woher die einzelnen geldströme
eigentlich kommen die mehrwertsteuer zum
beispiel von den verbrauchern bestimmte
sonntag steuern von speziellen branchen-
und so weiter
danach können wir beurteilen ob die
entwicklung der wirtschaftsdaten mit der
steuerdaten übereinstimmt wenn china
sagt dass seine industrieproduktion um
10 prozent gewachsen ist dann sollten
die steuererträge aus der industrie auch
entsprechend gewachsen sein und
natürlich tun sie das nicht diesen
diagramm könnt ihr die abweichungen
zwischen den steuererträgen und den
offiziellen wirtschaftsdaten nach
branchen geordnet
und wenn ihr genau hinschaut werdet ihr
feststellen dass die abweichung zwischen
beiden zahlen völlig zufällig sind es
ist also sehr wahrscheinlich dass china
einfach mit seinen eigenen zahlen herum
spielt wenn es den einzelnen akteuren
nützlich erscheint kommen wir nun zur
abschließenden schlussfolgerung der
studie denn das ist verdammt starker
tobak
[Musik]
nach unserer besten schätzung könnte die
tatsächliche wachstumsrate des bip von
2008 bis 2016 um fast zwei prozentpunkte
zu hoch angesetzt seien eine forensische
untersuchung der volkswirtschaftlichen
gesamtrechnungen chinas 2% jahr für jahr
wenn dies zutreffe würde es bedeuten
dass chinas reales bip heute um zehn
prozent niedriger liegt als das was man
uns glauben machen will
auch dies bedeutet nicht dass hier ein
alter zeitig gewachsen wäre aber das
wachstum fiel wohl die ganze zeit
langsamer aus als wir uns immer gedacht
haben all dies führte zu einem weiteren
verdacht wenn die chinesen bezüglich
dieser zahl so lange belogen haben was
ist dann mit all ihren anderen zahlen
tatsächlich ist ist nicht das erste mal
dass wir den finanzen dieses landes
nicht über den weg trauen können
im jahr 2008 haben viele chinesische
unternehmen geschummelt als sie an den
amerikanischen aktienmarkt gehen wollten
wir sprechen hier von nicht
existierendes fabriken gefälscht
pflanzen und künstlich aufgeblähten
umsätzen und gewinnen es brauchte ein
team von wirtschaftsdetektiv die wie in
einem spionage film vorgängen um diese
betrügereien zu entladen mehr über ihre
arbeit können einen dokumentarfilm mit
dem titel china hassen erster haben die
filmemacher sind kein sponsor von uns
dies ist nur eine kleine empfehlung an
euch den link zum film könnt ihr in der
beschreibung unter diesem video finden
und jetzt die frage an euch glaubt ihr
wirklich dass china bei der buchführung
in diesem ausmaß betrogen könnte es auch
andere betrugsfälle geben von denen wir
noch gar nichts ahnen welche folgen
könnte dies alles für die weltwirtschaft
haben wir freuen uns wir immer auf eurer
klugen und wohlüberlegten beiträge im
kommentarbereich und wisst ihr
eigentlich dass wir jede woche neue
frische und informative videos für euch
vorbereitet und veröffentlichen wenn ihr
also keines dieser aktuellen updates
verpassen wollt abboniert bitte
regionalpolitik und drückt danach bitte
auch auf die klingel taste wenn euch
dieses video gefallen hat dann geht uns
auch einen daumen hoch bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]